good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast I am so sorry we were
late
someone forgot that they were co-hosting
today look and I'd love the opinions
everybody it wasn't me
I love the opinions of everybody
watching when you have a commitment or
you have a meeting is it common courtesy
one day before to say hey just a
reminder like tomorrow or two days
before or the morning of or three days
before okay four days make sure we could
go on the Thursday confirming this week
yes sure probably could have followed up
yesterday today said I'm excited for
today but that just means you don't show
up if you don't get that text no so the
issue was was that as everybody knows
I'm here
filling in for Claudia as she's on tour
yeah you can go to the dirty jeans
tour.com that's actually you can go to a
girl with no job comm four tickets for
the dirty jeans whose dirty jeans store
calm seems like a very valuable well
she'll have probably you know it is but
her for her next work jeans but to still
be girl with no job yeah so I was
talking with Claudia last night and
she's like oh can you see this apartment
at twelve o'clock and we were just like
talking about like all the stuff I was
gonna do this morning that didn't
involve the toaster said so never even
crossed my mind
but I'm here good morning good morning
we're happy that you're here we're so
you know that's the beauty of the
internet like we can do that we have
such a fun show because you haven't been
here in a while we must catch up with
you you've launched the fits you have
your quito season merch which I'm so
supportive and wearing god I can't
believe that like Gina had decked out my
[ __ ] merch you're the number one
morning show amongst Millennials in
America and in the world I think and
you're not wearing it
on Monday um you can come back on the
next time that Claudia is not here you
can't come Monday um the next time Claud
he's not here when's your next show
one sec I think in September cool well
at least I'm wearing it this show see
it's a cool one - that is a friends
inspired merch item yeah it's a nice one
it's a really nice one I've been waiting
for an excuse to wear it and today is
perfect it's really comfortable then
also after my segment with Ben you're
getting the boot because we have to love
Islander is joining us Alex and Dylan
alex is an OG toaster and I'm so excited
to talk to her about what it was like to
go on a reality show whilst being a
toaster you know and like how amongst
other things so it's just gonna be
really fun
but we're here and we're delayed but
we're here so we're delayed we're fine
we're fine but we have some tights you
have to do I guess we'll just have to
talk even faster than usual mm-hmm so
but what's good with you has the shit's
the shits is great in case any of you
don't know which I'm sure that you don't
because I'm getting like eight to ten
thousand views an episode and I think
that the they're like a hundred million
of you so if any of you want to support
me and listen to the schvitz that would
be great it is a sports podcast humor
you know like I can't do anything
without being funny yeah and I just like
shoot the [ __ ] with my friends Jack and
Victor and it's it's been a little tough
because you don't have dry periods in
entertainment
if somebody's always [ __ ] so sorry
somebody's always sleeping with somebody
somebody's always like cheating on their
husband or like somebody trips and falls
and goes to jail
like there's a dope always being
murdered in prison and it's being called
suicide and only the morning toast is
willing to get to the bottom of it yeah
that's always happening around here
totally for don't worry I mean I'll be
talking about it cuz I'm like a dog with
a bone
Oh fun oh yeah I'm like Theodore for
chairman yeah so it's been a bit of a
low it's like not that I don't love
women's soccer but like the podcast
isn't supposed to be only about women's
soccer and not that I don't love golf
but the podcast isn't only supposed to
be about God yeah well you're revving up
for the big seasons about to hit and now
at least you have your establish macu
and your co-hosts have gotten better at
what you do and this has just been like
warm-up this is preseason
warm-up so so far we are releasing on
Tuesday mornings but we are about two
weeks away from having an NFL specific
segment weekly so we're gonna go in two
days a week Tuesdays and Thursdays
exciting yes it's called the NFL schvitz
for anybody that plead NFL Blitz I don't
know where you Blitzer I have to say I
was not heard of the name though like no
but that doesn't mean anything because
we didn't grow up with brothers or
anything yeah NFL Blitz as well maybe
Olivia played blitz
I feel like she would know NFL Blitz she
might well she might know it because of
her man like she's super involved an
accomplished is a very popular game
whatever power take Matt Schmidt splits
whatever cute yeah cute okay it's really
fun that's really the boss yes
TNN that's why you guys should really
support tienen chef well this Fitz is
great cuz you can like send your like
boyfriend there when he's annoyed with
you for watching the toast then we also
have the snatcher on TNN and it's really
just a family affair over here and we
couldn't be more pleased this natural
air is a great great show it's a great
show it's killing it in the charts
showing him like our second episode is
still number six in TV and film the
snatcher was like still number three and
TV and film
unbelief she's just there to stay and
I'm so happy for her I guess the people
care more about The Bachelor than they
do about I mean it really is a sad state
of affairs but it is what it is anyways
I think without further ado we should
jump into the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast because
there's a lot to get through today a lot
of ongoing stories that I'd love to get
your thoughts on um however before we do
that I would like to let you know that
today's episode is brought to you by
green chefs I love green chef and
honestly it's the perfect sponsor for
today's episode with you because they're
at home meal kits that are super like
specific and curated to your dietary
needs and what you like and what you're
looking for so you could let them know
that you are a big proponent of keto
season and then they'll make that happen
do you though they'll send you a keto
season meal would you say that their K
disease I would say great chef lets you
choose from a wide array of
easy-to-follow life styles with select
or
ingredients recipes are quick and easy
with step-by-step instructions chef tips
and photos guide you along
everything is hand-picked and delivered
right to your door green chef's expert
chefs designed flavorful recipes for
your lifestyle that go way beyond
ordinary substitutions diverse arrays of
meal plans with plenty of options to
choose from so you can actually enjoy
sticking to your goals yeah that's like
a big thing to do you enjoy sticking to
your goals huge green chef is a USDA
certified organic company meal plans
include keto paleo balanced living and
plant powered so obviously I've done
green chess I've done keto plans which I
love but you can also have like a
vegetarian option keto vegetarian I
think that's what I would classify Maya
Unitarian keto terian it sounds like a
dog like a keynote area that's really
sure and really cute
anyways green chef has everything you
need for your diet attorney needs to
make it easy to cook at home which is
just already so hard to begin with so
they're making it a lot easier green
chef is also a part of hello is owned by
hello fresh so together they offer a
wide array of meal plans to choose from
there's something for everyone and I
personally love switching between both
brands when my palates change or you
know I want something specific or I want
them to tell me what I want you just
never know so for a total of seventy
five dollars off that's twenty five
dollars off each of your first three
boxes go to green chef comm slash toast
seventy five that's green chef calm /
toast 75 for twenty five dollars off
each of your first three boxes for a
total of seventy five dollars off quick
that was quick
just like talking about meal plans and
stuff so I started with Matt from the
live method training and the problem
with that is that if I post something
key to season that's not Kido there's a
lot of shady it's not she Matt knows
what I'm up to like I can't tell him
like oh yeah I took the bread off of
that pastrami sandwich last night
because he saw me eating a pastrami
sandwich and like look that's a good
level of accountability
it is it's just like we've we've had a
tough week did Claudia talk about the
flood of course okay so we had a flood
you guys know that we're living in
shambles it's just a stressful week and
what do you do when you have a stressful
week you break your diet yeah like
that's just what that's what happens
yeah honestly I'm a stress eater I ate
so much yesterday I just like couldn't
be stopped and I couldn't care less
um well I think it's because we started
the show earlier we did a 9:30 episode
so my day was just thrown off suck it
came home avocado toast on Jeju crackers
fiber one bar then I was eaten like
popcorn Weight Watchers I screamed then
I guess that's not terrible then we went
to dinner and oh I was also like just
snacking my way through town you know
when there's like free snacks around
town and you're just like scooping them
all up yeah a couple baked by Melissa's
in there we went to dinner he just ate
everything in sight baklava it's a heavy
fibered morning zucchini chips those are
so [ __ ] good we went to opera ooh
delicious [ __ ] delicious so you go
Gigi crackers and then a 5 or 1 bar I
well I was like I was too impatient to
make the avocado toast so I had to eat a
fiber one bar like while I made it
that's how hungry I was
mm-hmm that's like a a big mince a lot
of fiber that is a lot of fiber and that
promotes a big movement I have nothing
to show for it nothing nothing you're
lying
clogged up clogged that just like your
pipes yep okay well let's get into the
news of the day because Jeffrey Epstein
autopsy is here and you know what
they're actually giving us more
information than you thought that they
might have autopsy finds broken bones in
Jeffery Epstein's neck deepening
questions around his death deepening
questions in autopsy found that
financier Jeffrey Epstein I'm still
gonna question this word financier
because I was financier no because I was
seeing articles today that he actually
has no money he's not a billionaire
everything he did was a Ponzi scheme and
he like is just a way for people to move
dark like for billionaires to move their
money like around and to like buy
islands and abused young people so just
that was his whole life like I don't
know I need to read more about it but
everyone's just assuming that he's like
this big financière like I think he's
just like a puppet in someone else's
like financial scheme very interesting
alleged financier Jeffrey Epstein
suffered multiple
his neck bones according to two people
familiar with the findings deepening the
mystery about the circumstances around
his death among among the bones broken
in Epstein's neck was the hyoid bone
which in men is near the Adam's apple
such breaks can occur in those who hang
themselves particularly if they are
older according to forensic experts and
Studies on the subject but they are more
common in victims of homicide by
strangulation the expert said kaboom
kaboom so it but still it's like it's
possibly committed suicide so we're
gonna keep going down this road it's
also possible that he was murdered by
someone who didn't want this to ever go
to trial which includes so many people
where do we even begin it's possible I
mean sorry it's impossible yeah he did
not kill himself and like not to beat a
dead horse by the way that's a terrible
expression why we used to beat a dead
horse for the horses why would I beat a
dead horse
why would I beat a horse at all I don't
know but not not to go down that path
but if you're I know that you spoke
about this if you're under 24-hour
suicide watch and you're in suicide
prevention
you just can't kill yourself yeah well
then you can't hang yourself I wouldn't
I see a rope and I and I'm like a bucket
pail is everything to you I tie it up
they get impale the jump they don't have
all those resources in prison so he used
his bed sheet and then I guess he like
jumped from the bed but I was talking to
someone who doesn't dabble so heavily in
conspiracy theories like I do and so
their theory is that like at the very
least a guard left like he was left
unattended so that he could commit
suicide so like someone was just paid
off to leave him alone so he could
commit this suicide maybe like which is
a more palatable theory than someone
coming in and murdering him or even more
palatable or someone coming in putting
in a fake body elbow taking him away
back to the island so he can keep
abusing people yeah that one's strong
but what about the guard killing him
that could be it guards he had all the
time oh oh so we have to issue a
correction because yesterday we told
this story about an excerpt in the New
York Times article where the guard said
that he was switching shifts with a guy
named Steve jail and someone posted this
tweet where they highlighted this
excerpt from the New York
where the guard was like I switch got I
switch ships with this guy I didn't know
I asked him what his name was he said
Steve I said what's your last name he
looked around and said Jail and I
thought you know seems legit my god but
that was all fake okay someone tweet was
fake the excerpt in the article was fake
so we reported fake news here on the
show which really really oh my god
that's us that we did that oh [ __ ]
hilarious but everyone believed it and
it's just so funny how literally at no
one including us in this situation did
their due diligence actually I was
actually going to the New York Times
article to UM just like to read that
paragraph and like see if there was
anything else but I'm not a New York
Times subscriber and I already use my
monthly amount of articles that I can
read because of all this Jeffrey Epstein
stuff so I couldn't read the article
can't afford an airtime subscription
like times are tough I just I don't know
I feel like I've recently started
subscribing to I now get the paper at
home I also started a women's wear daily
subscription and I have not used it once
so I don't want to subscribe to
something else until I'm getting the
most out of the do things I'm
subscribing to pretty good pretty good
so anyways that's the latest on the
Jeffrey Epstein autopsy all very shoddy
better in WA very show day yeah and I'm
really upset that there's no one named
Steve Dale no what's his last name do
you do that's like you know we were
saying it's like The Dictator what's
your name employees yes like employees
must wash hands Allison burgers okay
next story a little update ASAP rocky
has been found guilty of assaults but he
but spared jail in Swedish trial so
Robert ASAP rocky was found guilty of
assault Wednesday by a Swedish Court but
will avoid further jail time the rapper
was handed a suspended sentence after
the court found that the assault was not
quote of such a serious nature as to
warrant more time behind bars
rocky was arrested in Stockholm July
after he and two members of his
entourage got into a street brawl with
Mustafa Jafari who's 19
prosecutors asked the court to convict
mayors that's a sob rocky and sentence
him to at least six male rocky mayor
but the prosecution failed to prove the
extent of the seriousness of the attack
okay well Aesop Raffi is back home in
the US this has been like such an
international stir yep um I'm glad he
doesn't have to go back and go back to
prison but this is just a really crazy
story yeah it's also gotten way too much
media attention yeah like he came back
it's done he was and now he's convicted
like he was sitting in jail awaiting
trial yes
and now the verdict has come down but I
guess he'll just like never go back to
Sweden again is that how it works I
guess and I've heard Sweden is lovely
like I don't know if you need to go
twice yeah it's probably like a one-time
you go you see the lagoons see the sea
to see the blond people everyone's
blondes Jews don't belong in Sweden we
can't go to Sweden
yeah man hey we picked out like a sore
thumb yeah I had no plans no but I I
have seen you know like random travel
instagramers they like post like that
gorgeous picture like holy [ __ ] I have
to go find wherever the water is so blue
yeah and it's usually Sweden does that
do that for you do you see pictures I
mean show me I have to go yeah where do
you want to go sweden but I can't go but
you can no Jews can't go to Sweden until
somebody tells me that I can go to
Sweden I've never heard of Jews thriving
in Sweden what about like the Swiss Alps
is that Swedish yeah it is it is I guess
we could go on the Alps it's like we're
wearing a helmet nobody would know no
one would know no no well I'm glad he's
back home there's I don't think there's
anything scarier than being like locked
in a barn good know the hope sorry
to clarify that whole story of him being
locked away in a foreign country and not
being allowed to leave very scary very
newsworthy yeah but once he got back
here like okay there's no more jail yeah
like what's craziest this was causing
like international relations like
foreign policy issues like between both
countries but I guess you know he's a
big guy here like we're gonna stand up
for I don't know our man we have to
stand up for him plus there was a video
and the whole assault thing was like it
was all [ __ ] I also like the
alleged I don't know you getting a
street fight you have to go to jail
street fights all the time yeah no no
and according to him like they attacked
like this guy attacked him and his crew
so it's funny I actually I'm like one
degree of separation away from ASAP
Rocky you are yes are you gonna send him
quito season merch I should that's
actually a really good idea but I've
heard that he's so so nice like really
just like a sweet his producer is a very
religious Jewish man that actually not
his family's religious he's not very
religious but I'm just saying close to
home nice guy we can all not go to
Sweden totally and the Swiss apps are in
Switzerland so we can still notice oh
this Alps very good sweet next we're a
little fun news Rachel Bilson Adam Brody
reunite at JFK Airport did you see this
picture show me it's like he couldn't
wait to get out of the photo he couldn't
even stay for the flash you know what I
understand what happened here because
I'm this happened to me once too
whenever the picture when I took a
selfie with Kim Kardashian and I
accidentally had my front flash on so it
took a little bit longer than she
anticipated and she had already moved
away and that's what I think happened
here with Adam Brody's burglary face um
but Seth and summer are back together
The OC co-stars Rachel Bilson and Adam
Brody had a run-in at JFK Airport this
week quote ran into my old buddy from
JFK to LAX hashtag California here we
come bill simmered on Instagram
Wednesday along with a selfie of the duo
obviously she played summer Roberts and
he played Seth Cohen and this is photo
is all we have left I know this made me
sad like this didn't make me excited I'm
happy that you showed me the picture
because when you see it Adam know when
you said Adam Brody for whatever reason
my mind went to Brody Jenner and it was
because people are he's people are
talking about him yeah so that's not
Brody Jenner
that's Adam birdie that's Seth Cohen yes
you know yes yeah cute I don't know it
looks like a fan photo it made me
realize that they probably never really
even liked each other
oh they're also exes because they dated
on the show that's why it's so weird
yeah that out - max you're really quite
the man um so I don't know I feel like
everyone who's involved in the OC like
wants no part of it anymore
and it's always like sad to be reminded
of that there they're not rebooting the
OSI they're rebooting nine oh two one oh
mmm
just clarifying just letting people know
sad for the OSI that they couldn't get a
reboot I don't think anyone wants a
reboot like we're also like ashamed of
the show I don't get it I meant bent
Ryan Atwood Ben McKenzie once and like
it was through a work thing so but
anyways he was so like not about
embracing the Ryan Atwood of it all I
understand
reality shows are tough it's not a
reality show cool but I'm glad that we
have this expert here that's why we're
talking about 9:00 on to I know I'm just
bringing back you know neither us who
went to sell so not a reality show
those are heavily come on aren't they
scripted you're thinking about the hills
cool cool thoughts on my beard it's new
oh my god you know I think I'm like your
number one hater of your beard it's
gotten better now that it's growing out
but I actually like I'm I don't notice
anything like Zach could literally grow
a beard down to the floor and I and I
would not notice I don't notice haircuts
I don't know especially for a man like I
don't notice a thing but for some reason
your beard it's like so I'll tell you
what obvious to me because since the day
I was born I've had cheeks as soft as a
baby's bottom shave every day nothing I
like it soft and that's it
and now you seeing some scruffy well you
know what the first few weeks of you
growing out your beard it was highly
uncomfortable that's probably buddy
haven't seen me but today when you came
in I didn't notice the beer today until
you mentioned it so it's becoming more a
part of your face yes
is that a good thing yes hmm but like I
just don't know how you survived those
first few weeks like how they let you
into work and stuff and like I didn't
look in the mirror I just didn't exist
you probably assumed you were sitting
Shiva because there's really whatever
like it didn't exist god forbid no but
that's what it looks like some of them
who have to be carry out their beard
yeah people were messaging me about the
nine days and I was just like yeah
that's that's what I'm doing it for so
now that you is this peak beard like
alright is it gonna get work we're
letting this puppy grow I'm gonna see
where it goes you know it's it's just
for experimentation purpose
like I don't know you could dye your
hair or you could grow at your armpit
hair I've seen that that's a trend like
yeah like you could people grow hair
some people dyed their hair like you
know they're going through a change they
want they want to embody that change
some people got their armpit hair they
like want to make a statement you know
after you to the picture feeds so like
is this a statement is this a change are
you just really [ __ ] bored
I'm just trying new things I mean I'm in
that phase just like Isis also Claudia
doesn't seem to care so it's rare that I
can do something where she where it
doesn't bother her yeah so like I got
the green light so I'm gonna grow this
baby to the ground imagine I just like
grew a beard I can see you with like a
big beard like Lou combs beard beard IVA
a beard yes I don't think I'm doing that
I think I have about a week left I think
you're going through a midlife crisis
you do yeah because you also started
working at the live method which is like
a great you know way to interpret a
midlife crisis like oh I'll get in shape
is I really just treating your sweatband
all around town that's true so if it
just stays there by the way it should be
framed it should be it's just like it's
like a part of the live method Museum
Olivia ran into it I really felt like
Miss Trunchbull to whom does this
disgusting ribbon belong to by the way
there was no sweat in it I never wore it
I put it on because of my egg head I
also think that this helps with the egg
head I think I look a little less eggy
okay it's also like night my hair Thanks
or less eggy but how does Theo feel
about it Theo loves me no matter what
and I love him no matter what we have a
very very special father-son bond he's
so cute he's so [ __ ] cute I love him
the booty of a champ you're really doing
a great job raising him he's a great
booty would you agree oh yeah personally
when he splits back that ass up okay
next step we can talk about animals
babies um we couldn't like if you feel
like passionate I just feel like we went
from beating a dead horse which was so
cruel so now we need to sexualize dogs
okay I do what you got to do man
here's this I guess I'm the show he does
not represent the shows he's not a
reflection of the shows at Megan's or
intentions be next up we have a little
business coupled with some influencer
news and I thought you might find this
interesting
Arielle Charnas something Yogi Len lands
10 million dollars in funding
one of the biggest influence are funding
rounds to date okay so Arielle tarnis
announced on her Instagram today with a
business of fashion article that I do
not subscribe to so I found us an OPS of
the article online from the fashion log
are you [ __ ] kidding me
what 10 million dollars Oriol Charnas
listen to this our influencer Arielle
Charnas has landed 10 million dollars in
funding in a deal that values her
something Navy brand at nearly forty
five million dollars according to
business of fashion stylish - one of the
early investor investor partners of
Tommy Hilfiger and Michael Kors is
joined by box Group m3 ventures third
crime ventures and Rent the Runway
co-founder Jennifer flies in what is
quote one of the biggest funding rounds
secured by an influencer to date Charnas
whose ongoing partnership with Nordstrom
comes to a close at the end of the year
she will use the funds to build a
direct-to-consumer quote lifestyle brand
okay
all across the board I find this so
interesting Claudia Knight she's always
in the news like this influencer and
we're always like on this show signing
somehow like defending her because she's
always like catching hey this isn't hey
this is actually really exciting and I
think it's really interesting for the
business of influencing so I do want to
get your take on that but she posted
today saying that you know something
maybe is gonna become more of an a
lifestyle brand I guess it'll be like
more ecommerce and retail who knows but
this is like a big deal huge for you
know traditional investors to be taking
a chance on an influencer like this and
I think she's a great place to start
because I think what she's doing with
her business is really cool her
collaboration with Nordstrom was so
successful she like kept breaking their
website but it's coming to a close at
the end of this year and I think overall
that's like good for all parties
involved because that I think there were
some issues there I just freaked out at
the 10 million because that's a lot of
money and it was before you continue to
read the rest of the article yeah I
think that this is awesome I think that
it's something that they've been doing
in alcohol for a really long time where
I'm sure that I mean there's been way
more than 10 million dollars investment
influencers and alcohol brands uh yeah
but that but that would be like a
tangible brand like they're investing
ten million dollars in valuating her her
so is it in something Navy yeah like
something Navy is becoming more than
what it is right now more yeah okay so
she'll probably have a clothing line
that's all hers like that she owns one
hundred percent that's not just
licensing and I don't know what I mean
obviously they have big plans it's worth
the forty five million dollars but I
think it's a game-changer is it I don't
but then he's also like the bubble but I
don't think that it is like she sold
four million dollars worth of
merchandise at Nordstrom like I think in
her initial launch of her collection
holy [ __ ] good for her yeah plus like
combined with all of the ads I don't
think they're buying like her brand
deals or anything but like I think she
pulls in a good amount of money yeah I
think so too
especially given her sighs she's not
that like she's not huge
that's what's interesting about this
choice and I was reading in the toast
this is where I learned about today the
toast bog and tea group where people
were commenting on like what this means
and she has 1.2 million followers which
is so much but it's not by any means
like the most of any influencer yeah so
but I think what she's doing in terms of
making her brand of business is
cutting-edge and that I don't think any
other influencers we're looking for seed
funding no it's like kind of the not
what the betches tried to do but batches
became a media company right yeah that's
how they started what started us like a
blog website but it really says like a
publishing platform yes so it's like
sort of similar except it seems like
something maybe it's doing it a little
bit better I don't I don't know if it's
the same I'm trying to think about not
the same but like using an Instagram
account to for something more than
direct influencing like it's not just an
influencer there is a huge company
behind you that you're trying to build
yeah do you ever I'm saying
sorta I don't think betches is the right
comparison because but then you also
look at like Cara Frog me who I think is
the best
fashion influencer out there right now
and like she has a brand but that does
really well in it so if I can cute but
she's not like getting she's not being
treated like a tech company told in this
way yes so it's an interesting way to
look at it yeah it's like like
influencers launch collabs all the time
and I think every big fashion influencer
has some sort of clothing line or so
there's something different about what
they're trying to do here is totally is
what I'm gleaning or maybe they're just
calling it an international fashion
lifestyle brand and like maybe at the
end of the day that really does mean
nothing which is what we've all thought
it's great it could just be branding
yeah I don't know I know but I kind I
would admit like I mean no one's I'm not
investing any money but I'm just saying
like hypothetically like I'd like what's
the tube for horse racing like I bet I'm
like her horse you know but like I think
I just like completed like I don't have
a horse in this race sourcing that
you're betting on got it if you if you
were thinking about investing you would
think about investing with her yeah like
if someone was like okay you have to
invest in in one of these five
influencers and like I don't know who
the other four were but she's one of
them I would I would really consider for
sure terms of investing in influencers
she's at the top of what she knows what
she's doing she also is professional
like the more and more I meet and learn
about other people in this space
everyone is so not professional and
nobody values the money that they're
getting they're like oh this brand is
like willing to pay me 4x and like
though like send in their stuff late or
they'll like not show up to the other
side of it I see from everywhere yeah
it's just like people are not like you
this is your job
like sure it didn't start off as your
job it started off if you're a great
influencer probably is
you're not trying to make money you just
blew up and then all of a sudden you can
be a media property that sells ads or
creates clothing or whatever it may be
but like most of them are not
professional at all especially the
bigger that they get they become very
egotistical and yeah so I would
definitely invest in her she
seems like a professional lady totally
and you know if you're just looking to
shop check out honey because saving
money is something that we can all agree
on
honey is a free browser extension that
scans the web for coupon codes and
discounts while you shop online it's
[ __ ] sick I've been using honey since
before we've been working with them on
the show and like I'm so excited to be
out here and like evangelize about honey
because it's it's free money so easy
it's sorry about honey after you finish
yeah it works on over 220 thousand sites
like Amazon Nordstrom j.crew Nike Best
Buy Target Macy's and more it takes zero
effort to install just two clicks and
you'll start saving any time you shop
online so I use honey it's like a
browser extension and it come anytime
you're shopping online honey will
automatically get to work for you find
the best discount codes discounts out
there and you will get the best possible
price so I use it all the time when I
shop at like revolve there's like all
these hidden discount codes that they
get me and anytime I shop anywhere like
honey is getting me the best prices so
everyone should check should check it
out it's so simple to use it really does
sound too good to be true but it's free
and it saves you money so like what is
the catch there is none there's really
no no reason not to use honey it's free
to use and easy to install on your
computer in just two clicks don't take
it from us take it from our listeners
hate from everywhere and truly get honey
for free at join honey calm slash toast
that's join honey calm / toast honey
online savings simplified I can't stress
this enough like it is one of its just a
brilliant invention I'd like brilliant I
don't know what I did before honey
actually I was just giving away my money
it's the equivalent of going to
Bloomingdale's checking out somebody
handing you a 10% off coupon you saying
no I don't want that totally not
downloading honey I have a new I'd like
to come up with slogans for our
advertisers while we save your money
download honey that's good that's pretty
good pretty good
it's pretty good okay fifth and final
story a little more business before we
bring out our love I lenders by lenders
lye lenders how we work is trying to
justify it's a tech company valuation so
we work uh which is officially known as
we company release paperwork to go
public on Wednesday in it the co-working
company tried
to defend its whopping seven forty seven
billion dollar valuation 47 billion yes
even though Oh Mike they're operating at
a huge loss losing nearly nine hundred
million dollars in the first half of
2019 so I so much to say that we work by
the way but you can go this is like just
another one in and another tech
valuation a tech company going public so
it is unprofitable which is like I'm not
a financier but I just don't understand
like how you invest in a company that
doesn't make money I also don't
understand how companies who are like
getting money hand-over-fist like uber
aren't profitable like where are you
putting all your profits man because
like I'm paying you every single day in
customer acquisition and eventually
they'll I guess feel like they have
enough customers they can start churning
out cash but you're I have no idea my
problem with we work is that there are 1
trillion competitors the reason why it's
at 47 billion is because they are global
like truly global you go to Israel
there's we work you whatever there are
so many competitors we work is so
expensive the spaces are so small it's
just like the the idea and the novelty
of a shared office space dwindles when
you have that amount of competition
I agree but still we work is number one
like anything that's a good idea is
gonna have competition that doesn't mean
that it's like not that they should just
give up but I wonder if they do I'm not
saying I love they own all the real
estate of the buildings because like
it's like the founder which is where I
know most of my financial information
that's interesting because then they're
a real estate company that's not just a
tech bubble company the founder is the
greatest movie ever it opened my eyes to
everything it's like I I never I never
understood that Starbucks was a real
estate company yeah you're not even very
the real estate industry
I'm I'd be willing to bet that we work
does not own the majority of their
buildings I think they probably own some
and don't and rent others and rent
others you know yeah but even there the
the business proposition of renting and
then re renting it for way more because
they're cutting up the square footage so
much
still again it's a great business ya
know they're they're definitely know are
they profitable well I think they do
spend so much on advertising and like
all this jazz and like new customers and
new businesses and they're trying to be
like more than just a shared office
space company so I think they're really
in their infancy like I don't consider
oberus still in a place where they
should be like spending so much money to
acquire customers like it's been so long
but we work is still like developing
company so I understand why they're not
profitable yet but I don't understand
why you go public when you're not
profitable I just don't understand like
it's it seems like basic basic
arithmetic to me you know 47 billion
it's so much money they have to own all
their 47 billion for a company that's
losing money that just doesn't make
sense to me and this is just a general
thing with um with stocks and stuff oh
my gosh you ever watch American greed
yes I watched I think what was the
saddest episode I've ever watched I mean
they're all sad because at the end of
the day it's like people getting ripped
off um they just did an episode on the
college admissions scandal which I found
to be I guess cuz we were so in it and
we talked about it every day like I
found it to be boring because there was
absolutely no new information it was
just like a recap um but I watched one
from last season about a company called
telexfree which was an international
Ponzi scheme um like really targeting
well it eventually went to other
countries but in America really
targeting immigrants from because like
one of the founders was for Mozilla so
like all of these promotional videos
would be in Spanish and like it was like
this is where you belong this is where
you need to invest your savings like so
many people invested with them over the
course of their whole scheme they got
three billion dollars from 1 million
people and it's terrible it was just it
was so sad and it happened like it came
to light all in like 2017 so I was just
I couldn't we were reporting the news
back then like I just I can't leave I
didn't know about it was so sad I mean I
get a call I get them less now but I you
see it a call from the IRS all the time
like he would come up as a Washington
number and they're like hey you owe
$2,000 if you want you can give us a
debit card and we can run it for you
right now and like of course you gave it
to them no I called my job
freaking out I'm like what the [ __ ] like
what what happened
like been the IRS does not call you the
IRS ng letters and it's like the amount
of people that just give them their
credit card out of fear yes like that's
what these are they
oh no but that's not even what this was
this was people giving their money like
out of Hope and like just saying it's
easy to be skiing it's what it is and
this was just like such a terrible one
on such a big scale it was really sad
but anyways I need to watch more
American green because it's [ __ ]
crazy it's a crazy crazy show next week
they're doing an episode on fire
festival which i think is gonna be like
the College Admission scandal which it's
like I've already seen two documentaries
I don't know that there's much more you
can tell me but hearing something
narrated by Stacy Keach is always a good
time I want him to come on this show and
like narrate for us
cuz he has such a serious voice he's
doing fire I mean it was a big scheme
but it doesn't make enough money
no American greed is about either small
or big-time Ponzi schemes in America
otice or just schemes or people or like
women scheming men like small it can be
as small or as big like I'm sure they
did Bernie Madoff they also just did
like a woman who like schemed over this
like old very sad guy who owned a tree
farm it was so that was the saddest one
I had seen until telex free so there's
no scheme too big or too small which I
like I've told you my fire festival
story yeah so I used to work at a
company that got fire festival like you
get RF peed like people ask for your
submissions for doing marketing whatever
and fire festival asked and we put
something together and we sent it to
them and they said originally the launch
date was November or whatever and like
oh actually we can't do it in November
the president of the island said that
it's not going to be available and we
never heard from them and it launched in
November or whatever month it was yeah
so what I think they knew do you know
what I'm saying like like based on
watching documentaries i watch them know
I know that they knew but I'm saying
it's it seems like they didn't
intentionally start they didn't they
didn't set out for this to be fraudulent
[ __ ] up and then
refused to shut it down if you used to
take no for an answer I check I think in
general you know something more
encouraged to do is like not take no for
an answer but sometimes you just have to
accept that except the L speaking of L
that into love island we have Alex and
Dylan here I'm so excited to talk to
them so do you want to stay or do you
want to go we can decide we're gonna
push it out we'll see you in a few
minutes talk soon
stay tuned get a drink grab a snack
Gator season
you
welcome back islanders to the morning
toast
Alex Dillon thank you so much for being
here we're so I mean I'm so excited I've
been keeping up with the show and then I
found out that you are toaster and that
just made me like even more invested and
then I downloaded the app I really I did
yeah it was hard for me because I wasn't
always watching live so I never really
got to voc's I needed to like build up
episodes to watch together but I was in
it for you so you watch that you were
binge watching yeah I would like being
charged like three or four at a time but
I love the format of the show where it's
on while you guys are actually there and
it's like every night of the week so
even if it's not super fast paced like
it doesn't really matter like Wilson
will catch you guys tomorrow it's not
like all these cliffhangers so right now
I'm watching bachelor in paradise and
they keep saying the quality like they
could really learn a lot from the
structure of your guys's show so while
you were there the show was airing have
you seen the show we've only seen like a
few episodes the beginning ones so like
the ones that were not really good yeah
I was talking about I was like this show
is just so boring yeah I don't get it
and it has such rave reviews by the end
when Cashel and Kiara like reunited I
was truly crying they they have the best
music on your show like their oh yes oh
my god like what they're known for is
that the same yes how do you guys watch
the UK version before you went on the
show I did I did because I was obsessed
with it I watched like season 3 and I
was like oh my god I love it
so because it's the first show the first
season on the show in the u.s. how did
you get on the show what made you want
to do this show do you apply for other
shows like how did it work um my best
friend actually was like also in talk
she knew a guy that was casting for it
and so she was like I think my best
friend would be really good on this so
we both kind of just went through the
process together and then I just like
made it to the finals and then they're
like hey you want to come on the show I
mean I literally found out on a Friday
and I flew out to Fiji on Monday oh my
god yeah well that's like good thing you
don't have so much time to like worry
about it yes yes what about you I just
got they reached out to me and
I was just like TV cool I don't know
they kept us out and I just kind of went
with the process and then yeah I had
that five days so I say alright I'm out
here at pack your bags in the are the
way that it works say they bring in new
cast members how do you get to be part
of the original cast and then where are
the other cast members like waiting and
watching the show at home because you
came in like a little late so where were
you yeah I came in like three days into
the villa think we're two days yeah so I
was in Fiji
so how did you get to be part of the
original crew they just like honestly
like I don't even know I don't think
they knew until the very last second
yeah and that's actually part of I think
you know that's so cool is that we
actually had zero clue what was going on
ever yeah you had no idea we didn't have
her phone we didn't know what time of
day it was like we didn't know anything
I was going on and we were only and I
don't think that anyone knew what was
happening so we don't really have that
answer it's a sight no one knew I didn't
I didn't even know if I was coming in as
a og or not I guess original and then I
say new it was like oh they're in the
bill already yeah that's the other thing
like I don't think people get that we
didn't have our phones like we weren't
running our instagrams we had our
friends doing it so that was my next
question because they give you phones so
that you can get these text messages but
I'm assuming you can't just like be
scrolling Instagram Oh pictures of text
well it's so cute all the time and I
feel like The Bachelor they don't have
phones they have they don't ever like
get cute pictures it's just what
producers take event oh yeah that's like
one of the things that they wanted us to
do like take a million pictures just
have fun with it that's so fun yeah okay
so you didn't know at the time like how
many Instagram followers you are getting
that's so crazy so when your families
came and like you got to meet people
from the real world like what was the
first thing that you asked them that
like what's going on in the world I
literally looked at them and I was like
what is Instagram like and they were
like but you guys came off so well
throughout the entire show like really
fan favorites spoiler alert runner-ups
which is a huge deal the show is
like cutthroat it's hard to say a lot
stay on the island yeah yeah so like did
that feel great to know that like so
many people liked you
yeah it was so mirrored like honestly I
went in and when I coupled up with
Michael I was like oh I'm done but I was
feeling I was like the toasters are you
kidding yeah I really came you're like
fine liam hemsworth and I found them
really did there was it was kind of cool
for me because I got to watch the first
episode before I came out into the villa
so I got to watch the first episode and
I knew instantly that like she would be
my type so I kind of had this you know
not like a game plan but I came in I was
like hopefully she's not actually happy
with Michael and then she said she
wasn't it was just easy for me cuz we
clicked right away so it wasn't that
cutthroat for us cuz we were just always
a joy yeah like super chill which is
nice so we're obsessed with like reality
show logistics on the show and because
this is the first season of love island
like we know nothing so I just have like
logistical questions okay was there only
one shower yes yeah so how did that work
did everyone have like a shower Scott
like time of day or just everything it
was like a free-for-all I go in when you
can look and like people started
showering together I don't know if you
saw that like when I literally started a
rumor I was like Emily and wesson are
showering yes together but we had never
seen people shower together before yeah
yeah it was so interesting okay big
question that we got do they change the
sheets in between coupling ceremonies no
I don't think so what I think is they do
it every Sunday okay so like that's not
terrible but yeah but like it's not
great it's not great but I didn't know
if they changed oh no they don't because
I remember when weary coupled Michaels
like earbuds we're still in the bed okay
in fact yes no it's still on the bed
okay that's another question like I'm
sure everyone that sprays hands before
the show but then they like start to
fade but you guys still looks pretty tan
like what were you using I used st.
Tropez like just that mousse
laughs yeah everywhere you're on TV like
it's it's like no I so great how come no
one ever swam week was raining 24/7 we
always tell people like sitting around
the pool as if it was like hot lava and
you couldn't get in and then you wonder
over cianelli police oh you guys in the
pool in like the last night
so where cash was in that villa
man caster in the pool all the time okay
even we would have like we would get
bored and we do like diving contest or
yeah all the time
yeah they did the diving contest the
favorite aiming that some weird belly
flop is yeah okay so what's the deal
with alcohol on the show because it
seems pretty tame and I think that's a
CBS thing because we've had big runner
people tell us that they they only get
like alcohol like at certain times it's
just like beer and wine so is that what
it is yeah so it's we got one drink a
night okay and we said well he's per day
you're like no you're really struggling
yeah yeah cuz it's hard when you're
going into somewhere you don't know
anyone you're just like sitting there
you're like oh I'd love to be drunk
right now I might be able to talk to
everyone no totally and I think that's
why things develop like really likes me
on the show but it also makes sets you
up for like success in a real
relationship because you're so we're
around each other all the time knowing
that there's no distractions at all you
can't just look at your phone it's like
you guys are just together and there's
you're not drunk like there's no getting
drunk it's like you just gotta sit there
and talk yeah no one's doing anything
they regret the next day which like
makes it cool but it's that's why it was
like so slow to start yeah I assume
what's the deal with the water battles
they make you drink so much water like
or is dehydrated [ __ ] in the world they
never had my water bottle it was always
lost but it was more so that we didn't
use like the tap water cuz they have a
like a jug for us in different locations
around the villa and so they would just
like have us use that I think it was
also just like reduce using plastic
oh we're just using okay no that's
interesting about six trips classic
tries no but you think if you don't with
the straw
yes i strong match devices that is so
fun so overall like what was the best
part of the experience I think our date
like our last date yeah like bachelor
style it was insane
like so we were sitting up there like
happening this is not real and like we
landed on private island literally broke
with your date what was the worst part
of like having to be there we cooked
breakfast and then guys the guys always
woke up and we cooked breakfast for
everyone yeah there was a so funny
because we would always freak out like
joking around with the girls but we're
like all we do is give like all we do is
cook for you guys yeah they just get to
go get their nails done and all this and
like we're just stuck in the villa just
making them breakfast and bacon and then
they'd be they'd run in and eat
everything before we can even get grab a
come on
so who do you think I know you guys
haven't seen on the episodes but you
think there's any one or any couple that
like didn't get a fair shake or like has
been like misrepresented but I feel like
overall there's no one that anyone
really hates other than like the West
End stuff was a little yeah fishy was
weird
that [ __ ] was me who was it's crazy eh
what else started out like so slowly
like he couldn't catch a break and then
all of a sudden he's just got like likes
really and yeah I know I'm like no
except for for him and then every single
girl that came in was like I was like
they're totally gonna go for Dylan and
then they're like I like what ya know it
was it was shocking but now he's with
Emily are they still together
yes yeah they're currently in New York
right now yeah they were just with them
yes sweet yeah do you think there's any
of the four remaining couples that would
it have not shared the money
would you guys have a plan to show what
was your plan use everybody questions
yeah [ __ ] I didn't know that that was
part of the shut up
oh yeah just got the money and then I
guess they threw that in but it would
have been more interesting with a couple
like Emily and Weston
yeah I know you never know because they
were I mean we were to go the whole show
so it was never a question for us but
they were still getting to know each
other I don't think that would ever be a
question either I don't think either one
of them would have taken the money also
like if you do that online versus like
$100,000 - myself - taxes kind of Roz
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh you're like we
were sitting in there like watching them
win we're like come on and just shocked
the nation someone just take the money
so it'll be funny like yeah each other
yeah it would be crazy
so our caring casual together now yes
yeah is anyone else from the show like
to game and go back and they call up
Kristen he did I like them what I love
Kristen I like so much yeah she did not
get it like her she's gonna - yeah I
agree that was a tough it's weird how
they just like throw these wrenches into
you know you guys think it's just about
me coupling but then they're like okay
no America voted and we don't like you
guys it was also like sad for Cormac
when he had to go - I would have made
the total opposite choice I would have
kept kirsten and we're mad cuz they were
two people who hadn't had so much time
you know but you guys were like had
loyalty - no geez and like I know that
everyone was saying that like Carol came
off really annoying and like I have to
say like she is the funniest person I've
ever met my like like you would love her
really
yeah in the beginning oh my god she was
so annoying I didn't understand hi guys
by the end like her love story was so
sweet so like I came I really started to
like her but she did like I don't know
something I her personality just didn't
translate yeah it was like someone
mentioned to us when we got out like oh
my god her baby voice and we were both
like and I was like I have no idea what
you're talking about
and then I watched it and I was like I
never heard that in my life
Oh Mike was like I don't know her and
maybe with a current confessional what
was it yeah yeah interesting
okay well here's a fun fact I'm taking
some questions from the toasters because
I knew this but I forgot so when there
was a Dallas when Claudia did her show
in Dallas for the dirty jeans tour they
did like a huge pregame at this bar and
Weston was a photographer wait I think I
saw that and that he pretending he's
Australian
did he know that it was so crazy so like
there was a lot of like toast influences
in the house it admit was it hard for
you to not watch the toast I was dying
like I still haven't caught up like you
know i watch it every single morning at
work it was the only thing that got me
through work and I would sit there and
be like it turned out on today I was
like one of those crazy wants they'd be
like oh my god wait where do you like
worried that what we're gonna say about
you
yeah that's to show yeah well we're
toasters to support toasters and also
you guys did come up so well but even if
you were like who's nobody was even so
bad I guess what like Weston but I still
like it though yeah no it was a
different type of show where it was bad
you know yeah it is a different type of
show like it's really not the bachelor
no it's just like what you think it's
bachelor in paradise but it's not yeah
and that was like the point that they
made they were like we do not want to be
like that we want to be like we all want
to get along like we don't want that
kind of drama yeah and so it was really
nice like really all did it get along
yeah it's super like relationship driven
because even now you have so many like
real relationships outside of the bill
only okay so how has it been you've been
out now like a week and is it like super
different like it's a crazy that goes
where come home with the boyfriend and
Mike yeah thousand in Syrian Polly with
with him up my arm yeah where you guys
live
in no way not terrible yeah so it's like
a flower like we already I already did
the drive yeah yeah I surprised her yeah
I mean that's so easy I really love this
show like there are so many rain Cara
there's no other yes yeah oh my god okay
oh and they're awesome they're so far
together and I wait sorry I just look I
was thinking like whenever I was
watching reality shows and I was like
people can't fall in love that quickly
but I I want to make a point that like
being with someone 24/7 for a month it's
like you know everything about that I
totally read and there was nothing about
love Island that felt like a stretch as
a viewer whereas it does feel that way
on other like dating shows but you guys
are together all the time you're sober
all the time you're like living in your
sleep like you know every year bit about
something yeah and you're also like with
friends so you see what you're like like
in social settings like you see every
different side
it's just weird catching up with friends
and they're asking all these questions
or we get all these questions like is it
real is it like are you guys actually a
thing I'm like why it doesn't make sense
but I understand that other perspective
like of course we're real like of course
like think time does move so much slower
where everything's not shown and it's
just crazy how much you get to know
about someone in a day a day literally
feels like a week and a week feels like
a month and we were there for four four
weeks it felt like we were three years
yeah I was like I've been so it's great
I'm not we can't even catch up the real
life yet I watched it like a little bit
of yesterday's but my lean lamb burger I
saw the cherry spoon I heard yeah I'm
sorry yeah I was like but now we have a
newfound hope um I have a really great
question for you because every time you
guys got a text it was like a huge G on
the house did the producers make you say
it like that every time to scream it or
it just became a fun thing it was like
well that's like the nature of the show
I think just because it's so big in the
UK where they're like I got a text and
so yeah and so we would all do it but in
different versions like
even would always got it yes and then
like I don't know I would just scream
yeah that is so but the reactions were
pretty like we're genuine because we had
no cool was going on all the time so if
someone got a text or we're sitting here
or because I could text her randomly in
the villa and someone would get a tax
really what's going on you know so there
was like a really genuine reactions it
was just we I would scream it on the top
of my longest always hilarious what was
the most shocking dumping or recutting
of the summer mmm Kelsey moving was oh
yeah Kelsey dumping herself oh yeah
leaving like badass though she's so cool
yeah she really grew me and I also
really like saw it with her and lesson
that that was what was upsetting like I
understood why obviously like the
Mallory thing didn't work or even
Katrina who like seems like a perfect
woman she is up legitimately I'm like
shocking and I was like she must have a
boyfriend by now because oh my god for
sure she should be like The Bachelorette
because like she inspires like
everything she's everything yeah
everything okay cool no you know who's
actually the most shocking was when
Kristen got voted off and it was Jim and
Kristin because Jim and Kristin were
amazing together and it was like hey
America is about to vote someone off the
island we're like wait what and then and
was it forgot oh we had to choose the
end we couldn't we couldn't choose the
came in and Kristin together but their
relationship was like so good so that
was so shocking that was the first time
where we really had to make a tough
decision
and kick people off balance oh that was
terrible yes that one hurt me to say I
liked her life so when new people came
into the house everyone was like so nice
and welcoming to them even though
they're like trying to steal your man
was that like but it was really like
sweet like was that genuine or you just
didn't want to be an [ __ ] yeah no it
was like we all were saying we all have
a fair shot here we we're all on this
show like we all made it weren't no
one's better than Anne
person and just because I met him three
days before doesn't mean that he
shouldn't like go get to know someone
yeah and that's like I think why people
I think America people translate it
differently because in the UK it's like
it's very normal and so the American the
the American translation was kind of
like what what are they why are they
being so nice yeah someone's coming in
to like steal your man yeah but everyone
was really nice about it like they would
pull us aside I mean like hey I want to
talk to Dylan like are you okay with
that and I'm like yeah it's fine like go
talk to him
no that is really nice cool well thank
you so much meteor I'm all out of my
like a hundred rapid-fire questions I'm
so happy for you guys I'm happy for all
of the love found on the show I look
forward to following your journey where
can everyone follow you and keep up and
if you haven't watch love island yet
like I think it's all available in the
CBS app and there are a lot of
commercials but I sat through them so so
can you my Instagram's at Alex Stewart
11 I just my name add Dylan Carey love
it and Ben was here he's boy than a job
Ben's hopper Kido season merch is
available on Tuesday thank you so much
oh yeah I'm wrapping it today announced
wedding tomorrow will be podcast only
because I'm catching up with Claudia
before car show in Asbury Park New
Jersey so if you're going I will see you
there thank you guys love you who are
all like in the group's like voting for
you and it was really a joy to watch it
on the big screen
you